story and the committee about the
baseless claims mr trump wanted the
justice department to investigate
and that mr barr viewed those claims as
nonsense
today
we'll hear from jeffrey rosen the person
mr trump appointed to run the justice
department
after attorney general barr resigned
we'll hear from other senior justice
department officials also
together
these public servants resisted mr
trump's effort
to misuse the justice department as part
of his plan to hold on to power
and we will show that trump's demands
that the department
investigate baseless claims of election
fraud continued into january 2021
but donald trump didn't just want the
justice department to investigate
he wanted the justice department to help
legitimize his lies
to basically call the election corrupt
to appoint a special counsel
to investigate alleged election fraud
to send a letter to six state
legislatures urging them to consider
altering the election results
and when these and other efforts fail
donald trump
sought to replace mr rosen the acting
attorney general with a lawyer who he
believed would inappropriately put the
full weight
of the justice department behind the
effort to overturn the election
let's think about what that means
wherever you live in the united states
there's probably a local government
executive
a mayor
or county commissioner
there's also an official responsible for
enforcing the laws a district attorney
or local prosecutor
imagine if your mayor lost the
re-election bid
but instead of conceding the race
they picked up the phone
called the district attorney and said
i want you to say this election was
stolen
i want you to tell the board of
elections
not to certify the results
that's essentially what donald trump was
trying to do
with the election for president of the
united states
it was a brazen attempt
to use the justice department to advance
the president's personal political
agenda
today
my colleague from illinois
mr kinzinger and other witnesses will
walk through the select committee's
findings on these matters
but first i recognize our distinguished
vice chair miss cheney of wyoming for
any opening statement she's cared to
offer
thank you very much mr chairman
at this point
our committee has just begun to show
america the evidence that we have
gathered
there is much more to come
both in our hearings and in our report
but i'd like to take just a moment to
put everything we've seen in context
we've already seen how president trump
falsely declared victory on november 3rd
2020.
how he and his team launched a
fraudulent media campaign that persuaded
tens of millions of americans that the
election was stolen from him
donald trump intentionally ran false ads
on television and social media
featuring allegations that his advisors
and his justice department repeatedly
told him were untrue
we have also seen how donald trump
launched a fraudulent fundraising
campaign that raised hundreds of
millions of dollars again
based on those same false election fraud
allegations
we have seen how president trump and his
allies corruptly attempted to pressure
vice president pence
to refuse to count lawful electoral
votes
and obstruct congress's proceedings on
january 6th
and how he provoked a violent mob to
pursue the vice president and others in
our capital
we've seen how the president oversaw and
personally participated in an effort in
multiple states to vilify threaten and
pressure election officials
and to use false allegations to pressure
state legislators to change the outcome
of the election
seeing how president trump worked with
and directed the republican national
committee and others to organize an
effort to create fake electoral slates
and later to transmit those materially
false documents to federal officials
again as part of his planning for
january 6th
we have seen how president trump
persuaded tens of thousands of his
supporters
to travel to washington d.c for january
6th
and we will see in far more detail how
the president's rally and march to the
capitol were organized and choreographed
as you can tell
these efforts were not some minor or ad
hoc enterprise concocted overnight
each required planning and coordination
some required significant funding
all of them were overseen by president
trump
and much more information will be
presented soon regarding the president's
statements and actions on january 6th
today as chairman thompson indicated we
turn to yet another element of the
president's effort to overturn the 2020
election
this one involving the department of
justice
a key focus of our hearing today will be
a draft letter that our witnesses here
today refused to sign
this letter was written by mr jeff clark
with another department of justice
lawyer ken klukowski
and the letter was to be sent to the
leadership of the georgia state
legislature
other versions of the letter were
intended for other states
neither mr clark nor mr klukowski had
any evidence of widespread election
fraud
but they were quite aware of what mr
trump wanted the department to do
jeff clark met privately with president
trump and others in the white house and
agreed to assist the president without
telling the senior leadership of the
department who oversaw him
as you will see
this letter claims that the u.s
department of justice's investigations
have quote identified significant
concerns that may have impacted the
outcome of the election in multiple
states
including the state of georgia
in fact donald trump knew this was a lie
the department of justice had already
informed the president of the united
states repeatedly that its
investigations had found no fraud
sufficient to overturn the results of
the 2020 election
the letter also said this
quote
in light of these developments the
department recommends that the georgia
general assembly should convene in
special session
end quote and consider approving a new
slate of electors
and it indicates that a separate
quote
fake slate of electors supporting donald
trump has already been transmitted to
washington d.c
for those of you who have been watching
these hearings the language of this
draft justice department letter will
sound very familiar
the text is similar to what we have seen
from john eastman and rudy giuliani
both of whom were coordinating with
president trump to overturn the 2020
election
when one of our witnesses today mr
donahue first saw this draft letter he
wrote this quote
this would be a grave step for the
department to take
and it could have tremendous
constitutional political and social
ramifications for the country end quote
this committee agrees
had this letter been released on
official department of justice
letterhead it would have falsely
informed all americans
including those who might be inclined to
come to washington on january 6th the
president trump's election fraud
allegations were likely very real
here is another observation about this
letter look at the signature line it was
written by jeff clark and mr klukowski
not just for clark's signature but also
for our witnesses today jeff rosen and
richard donahue
when it became clear that neither mr
rosen nor mr donahue would sign this
letter president trump's plan
necessarily changed
as you will hear today donald trump
offered mr clark the job of acting
attorney general replacing mr rosen with
the understanding that clark would send
this letter to georgia and other states
and take other actions the president
requested
one other point
millions of americans have seen the
testimony of attorney general barr
before this committee
at one point in his deposition
the former attorney general was asked
why he authorized the department of
justice to investigate fraud in the 2020
election at all
why not just follow the regular course
of action and let the investigations
occur much later in time after january
6th
here's what he said
felt the responsible thing to do was to
be to be in a position uh to have a view
as to whether or not there was fraud and
frankly i think the fact that i put
myself in the position that i could say
that we had looked at this and didn't
think there was fraud
was really important to moving things
forward uh and i sort of shuddered to
think what the situation would have been
if the pr if the position of the
department was we're not even looking at
this until after biden's in office
i'm not sure we would have had a
transition at all
i want to thank each of our witnesses
before us today
for your role in addressing and
rebutting the false allegations of fraud
at the root of january 6th
and thank you for standing up for the
constitution and for the rule of law
of course not all public officials
behaved in the honorable way our
witnesses did
at the close of today's hearing we will
see video testimony by three members of
donald trump's white house staff
they will identify certain of the
members of congress who contacted the
white house after january 6
to seek presidential pardons for their
conduct
thank you mr chairman i yield back
without objection the chair recognized
the gentleman from illinois mr kensinger
opening statement thank you thank you mr
chairman and thank you to our witnesses
for being here
i'd like to start with a personal story
so in may of 2009 i returned from
service in iraq and i announced my
intention to run for congress
a big reason i decided to run for
congress was my motivation to ensure
freedom and democracy
were defended overseas
i remember making a commitment out loud
a few times and in my heart repeatedly
even to today
that if we are going to ask americans to
be willing to die in service to our
country
we as leaders must at least be willing
to sacrifice our political careers
when integrity and our oath requires it
after all losing a job is nothing
compared to losing your life
within the halls of power in the face of
a president that commitment can easily
be forgotten
presidential pressure can be really hard
to resist
today we'll focus on a few officials who
stood firm against president trump's
political pressure campaign when the
president tried to misuse the department
and install a loyalist at its helm
these brave officials refused and
threatened to resign
they were willing to sacrifice their
careers
for the good of our country
the department of justice is unique in
the executive branch
the president oversees the department of
justice yet the president's personal or
partisan interests
must not shape or dictate the
department's actions
the president cannot and must not use
the department to serve his own personal
interest
and he must not use its people to do his
political bidding especially when what
he wants them to do is to subvert
democracy
the president cannot pervert justice nor
the law to maintain his power
justice must
both in fact and law
be blind
that is critical to our whole system of
self-governance
during this hearing you'll hear time and
time again about the president's request
to investigate claims of widespread
fraud
our witnesses mr rosen mr donohue and mr
engel stood firm in the face of
overbearing political pressure
because they understood that their oath
was to the constitution and not to the
personal or political interests of the
president the president and his allies
became keenly aware that with legal
challenges exhausted and electoral votes
certified
their only hope
would be a last-ditch scheme to prevent
congress from certifying the win
thus throwing the entire system into
constitutional chaos
the president wanted the department to
sow doubt in the legitimacy of the
election to empower his followers and
members of congress to take action
if the department could just lend its
credibility to the conspiracies people
would have the justification they needed
to spread the big lie
so president trump ultimately wanted the
department of justice to save the
election was quote corrupt and quote
leave the rest to me
and the republican congressmen
as you will hear today the department's
top leadership refused
not surprisingly president trump didn't
take no for an answer he didn't accept
it from attorney general barr
and he wouldn't accept it from mr rosen
either
so he looked for another attorney
general his third in two weeks
he needed to find someone who was
willing to ignore the facts that is not
the norm
let's look at what attorneys general
democrats and republicans alike have
said about upholding their oath to the
constitution
attorney general
ultimately owes his loyalty on to the
integrity of the american people and to
the fidelity to the constitution and the
legitimate laws of the country that's
what he's ultimately required to do i
will be an independent attorney general
i will be the people's lawyer if however
there were an issue that i thought were
that significant that would compromise
my ability to serve
as attorney general in the way that i
have described that as the people's
lawyer
i would not hesitate to resign
as you and i discussed if the president
proposed to undertake
a course of conduct that was in
violation of the constitution that would
present me with
a uh a difficult but not a complex
problem
i would have two choices i could either
try to talk him out of it or leave
those other choices
the attorney general's position as a
cabinet member is perhaps unique from
all of the cabinet members yes a member
of the president's cabinet but the
attorney general has a unique
responsibility to provide independent
and objective advice to the president or
any agency
when it is sought and sometimes perhaps
even when it is not sought
everyone in that video from eric holder
to jeff sessions spoke as one about the
independence of the department
it's a point of pride at justice to
apply the law without the president's
political self-interests obtaining its
actions are dictating how it uses its
authorities
but president trump did find one
candidate at justice who seemed willing
to do anything to help him stay in power
let's hear what president trump's own
lawyer eric hirschmann had to say about
jeff clark's plan to overturn the
election i'd like to advise viewers this
video contains some strong language
and when he finished discussing what he
planned on doing
i said
good [ __ ] excuse me sorry f
congratulations you just admitted the
first step or act you take as attorney
general would be committing a felony and
violating rule 60. you're clearly the
right candidate for this job
so who's jeff clark an environmental
lawyer with no experience relevant to
leading
the entire department of justice
what was his only qualification
that he would do whatever the president
wanted him to do
including overthrowing a free and a fair
democratic election
president trump's campaign to bend the
justice department to his political will
culminated in a showdown on january 3rd
today we will take you inside that early
evening oval office meeting
where top justice department officials
met with the president
at stake
the leadership and integrity of the
department of justice
the meeting took about another two and a
half hours from the time i entered
um
it was entirely focused on whether there
should be a doj leadership change
i was sitting directly in front of the
president
jeff rosen was to my
right jeff clark was to my left
uh he looked at me and he understood
well the one thing we know
is you're not going to do anything you
don't
even agree that the concerns that are
being presented are valid
and here's someone
who has
has a different view so
why shouldn't i do that you know
that's how the discussion
i proceeded jeff clark was proposing
that
uh jeff rose would be replaced by jeff
clark
and
i thought the proposal was
assimilated what were clark's
purported bases for why it was in the
president's interest for him to step in
what would he do what would how would
things change according to mr clark in
the meeting
he repeatedly said to the president that
if he was put in the seat he would
conduct real investigations
that would in his view uncover
widespread fraud
he would send out the letter that he had
drafted
and that
this was
a last opportunity
to
sort of set things straight with this
defective election
and that he could do it and
he had the
the intelligence and the will and the
desire
to pursue these matters in the way that
the president thought most appropriate
and he was making a pitch and every time
he would get
clobbered over the head
he would like say like you know like a
call to order you know the president's
your decision you get the chance to make
this decision and you know you've hurt
everybody and you can make your
determination
and then we jump back in
and
you know
really clobber him i made the point that
jeff clark is not even competent to
serve as the attorney general
he's never been a criminal attorney he's
never conducted a criminal investigation
in his life he's never been for injury
much less a trial jury
um and he kind of retorted by saying
well i've done a lot of very complicated
appeals and civil litigation
environmental litigation and things like
that and i said that's right you're an
environmental lawyer how about you go
back to your office and we'll call you
when there's an oil spill
and
uh pat cipolloni weighed in at one point
i remember saying
you know that letter that this guy wants
to send that letter is a murder-suicide
pact it's going to damage everyone who
touches it
and we should have nothing to do with
that letter i don't ever want to see
that letter again
and so we went along those lines i
thought jeff's proposal course proposal
was nuts i mean this guy said at certain
point you know listen the best i can
tell is the only thing you know about
environmental and elections challenges
is they both start with e and based on
your answers tonight i'm not even
certain you know that
the president says suppose i do this the
pros i replace
jeff rosen with him jeff clark
what do you do
well we know these men before us did the
right thing
but think about what happens if these
justice officials make a different
decision
what happens if they bow to the pressure
what would that do to us as a democracy
as a nation
imagine a future where the president
could screen applicants to the justice
department with one question
are you loyal to me or to the
constitution
and it wouldn't take long to find people
willing to pledge their loyalty to the
man
we know many of president trump's vocal
supporters on january 6 also wanted the
justice department to do whatever he
asked as long as it meant he could stay
in power
they made sure justice department
officials heard his message as they
protested loudly
in front of the department on their way
to the capitol on january 6th
[Music]
live in dc we're marching to the capitol
here at the
department of justice right now telling
these powers to do their job
we're gonna take the capital
i want to take a moment now to speak
directly to my fellow republicans
imagine the country's top prosecutor
with the power to open investigations
subpoena
charge crimes and seek imprisonment
imagine that official pursuing the
agenda of the other party
instead of that of the american people
as a whole
and if you're a democrat imagine it the
other way around
today president trump's total disregard
for the constitution and his oath will
be fully exposed
now let's get this hearing underway so
we can do our part to protect the
freedoms that we often take for granted
so that we can see how close we came
to losing it all i now yield back to the
chairman
we're joined today by three
distinguished witnesses
who each served in the trump
administration
in the months preceding january 6th
mr jeffrey rosen served at the
department of justice from may 2019
until january
2021
with president trump's nomination and
the confirmation of the united states
senate he became the united states
deputy attorney general in december 2020
he took the mammal of acting attorney
general
mr richard donahue has served in the
department of justice for over 14 years
miss donahue was a united states
attorney for the eastern district of new
york
then became mr rosen's principal
associate deputy attorney general and
finally acting deputy attorney general
mr donahue also served more than 20
years in the united states military
including the 82nd airborne and the
judge advocates general corps
we are also joined by mr steven engel
the former assistant attorney general
for the office of legal counsel
he was nominated by the former president
and confirmed by the senate during the
trump administration
he served from november 2017 to january
2021 and has now returned to private
practice
i will now sway in our witnesses the
witnesses will please stand and raise
their right hands
do you swear on foreign on the penalty
of perjury that the testimony you're
about to give is the truth the whole
truth and nothing but the truth so help
you god
thank you you may be seated
let the record reflect the witnesses all
answered in the affirmative i now
recognize myself for questions
first of all gentlemen thank you for
being here today
all of you served at former president
trump's pleasure at the department of
justice
in top leadership positions with
tremendous responsibilities
former attorney general bill barr told
the select committee that before he left
the department in december 2020
he told president trump on at least
three occasions
there were no evidence of widespread
election fraud that would have changed
the results of the presidential election
and refuted numerous specific claims of
election fraud the president was making
mr rosen
after mr barr announced his resignation
did donald trump continue to demand that
the department of justice investigate
his claims of election fraud
uh yes he
he uh asserted that he thought the
justice department had not done
enough
thank you from the time you took over
from attorney general barr until january
3rd
how often did president trump contact
you or the department to push
allegations of election fraud
so between
december 23rd and january 3rd the
president either called me or met with
me
virtually every day
with one or two exceptions like
christmas day
and
before that
because i had been announced that i
would become the acting attorney general
before the date i actually did
the president had asked
that uh rich donahue and i go over and
meet with him i believe on december 15th
as well
so after you had some of these meetings
and conversations with the president
uh
what things uh
did the president raise with you
so so the common element of all of this
was the president uh expressing his
dissatisfaction that the justice
department in his view had not done
enough
to
uh investigate election fraud
but at different junctures
uh other topics came up at different uh
intervals so
at one point he had raised the question
of having a special counsel for election
fraud
uh at a number of points he raised
requests that i meet with his uh
campaign council mr giuliani
at one point he raised the um
whether the justice department would
file a lawsuit in the supreme court
at a couple of junctures there were
questions about making public statements
or about
holding a press conference
uh
one of the later junctures
uh was this issue of sending
a letter to state legislatures
in georgia or other states
and
so there were different things raised at
different
parts of our different intervals with
the common theme being his
dissatisfaction
about what the justice department had
done to
investigate election fraud
i will say
that the justice department
declined
all of those requests that i was just uh
referencing
because we did not think that they were
appropriate based on the facts and the
law
as we uh understood them
thank you
so much donahue on december 15th the day
after attorney general barr announced
his
resignation
the president summoned you and mr rosen
to the white house
at this meeting with the president
what did he want to discuss
there were a number of topics of
discussion that day mr chairman
much of the conversation focused on a
report that had been recently released
relating to antrum county in michigan i
believe on december 13th
an organization called the allied
security group
issued a report that alleged that the
dominion voting machines in that county
had a 68 error rate um the report was
widely covered in the media we were
aware of it
we obtained a copy of it on the 14th of
december the day prior
we circulated to the u.s attorneys in
michigan for their awareness
and we had a number of discussions
internally but the the conversation with
the president on that day the 15th was
largely focused on that
and he was essentially saying have you
seen this report
he was adamant that the report must be
accurate that it proved that the
election was defective that he in fact
won the election and the department
should be using that report
to uh basically
tell the american people that the
results were not trustworthy and he went
on to other theories as well but the
bulk of that conversation on december
15th focused on antrim county michigan
and the asod report
thank you
mr ingle we know that attorney general
bar announced on december 1st 2020 that
the department of justice
had found no evidence of widespread
fraud that could have changed the
outcome of the election
so from december 1st 2020 until today
as you sit here
have you ever doubted
that top line conclusion
no i've never had any reason to doubt
attorney general barr's conclusion
thank you
pursuant to section 5 c8 of house
resolution 503 the chair now recognizes
the gentleman from illinois mr kings and
girl for questions thank you mr chairman
in the weeks leading to january 6 the
department of justice was fielding
almost daily requests from the president
to investigate claims of election fraud
each claim was refuted time and time
again an effort attorney general barr
described as whack-a-mole
when each of the president's efforts
failed he resorted to installing a new
attorney general to say the election was
illegal and corrupt simply so he could
stay in power
president trump started leaning on the
justice department the first chance he
got on november 29 his first television
interview after the election
where is the doj and the fbi in all of
this mr president
you have
laid out some serious charges here
shouldn't this be something that the fbi
is investigating are that
is the doj investigating
missing in action can't tell you where
they are republican congressman echoed
the president just two days later
they wrote a letter to attorney general
barr
laying into the justice department for a
quote shocking lack of action
in investigating the claims of election
fraud that same day attorney general
barr stated publicly that president
trump's claims had no merit
ignoring the top law enforcement officer
in the country republican congressman
amplified the stolen election message to
the american public let's listen
and so there's widespread
evidence of fraud
because people haven't done their jobs
durham
and barr
will deserve
a big notation in history when it's
written of the rise and fall of the
united states if they don't clean up
this mess clean up the fraud do your
jobs and save this little experiment in
self-government again i joined my
colleagues in calling on attorney
general bartu immediately
let us know what he's doing we're
already working on on challenging the
certified uh
electors and now what about the courts
how pathetic are the courts
january 6
i'm joining with the fighters in the
congress and we are going to object to
electors from states that didn't run
clean elections
democracy is left undefended if we
accept the result of a stolen election
without fighting with every bit of vigor
we can muster
the ultimate date of significance is
january 6. this is how the process works
the ultimate arbiter here the ultimate
check and balance is the united states
congress and when something is done in
an unconstitutional fashion which
happened in several of these states we
have a duty to step forward and have
this debate and have this vote on the
6th of january
today
is the day american patrons start taking
down names and kicking ass
mr donohue on december 27th you had a
90-minute conversation with the
president where he raised false claim
after false claim with you and mr rosen
how did you respond to what you called a
quote stream of allegations
the december 27th conversation um
uh in my mind an escalation of the
earlier conversations as the
former acting ag indicated there were a
lot of communications that proceeded
that as we got later in the month of
december
the uh
president's entreaties became more
urgent he became more adamant that we
weren't doing our job we need to step up
and do our job
and he had
this
arsenal
of allegations
that he wanted to
to rely on and so i felt in that
conversation that was incumbent on on me
to make it very clear to the president
what our investigations had rebuilt
and that we had concluded based on
actual investigations
actual witness interviews actual reviews
of documents
that these allegations simply had no
merit and i wanted to try to cut through
the noise because it was clear to us
that there are a lot of people were
springing his ear feeding him these
conspiracy theories and allegations and
i felt that being very blunt in that
conversation
might
help
make it clear to the president that
these allegations were simply not true
and so as he went through them in
what for me was a 90-minute conversation
or so what for the
former acting ag was a two-hour
conversation
um as the president went through them i
went piece by piece to say no that's
false that is not true
and to correct him
um really in a serial fashion as he
moved from one theory to another can you
give me an example of one or two of
those theories so uh one that was very
clear at that point uh was the antrim
county the asod report that i mentioned
earlier
allied security operations group
released this report that 68 error rate
there was in fact an antrim county a
hand recount
um had nothing to do with the department
the department did not request that that
was pursuant to
litigation brought by other parties but
there was a hand recount so they were
able to compare the henry account to
what the machines had reported
and for the
ballots that were actually counted by
the machine more than 15 000
there was one error one ballot
um and i did a quick calculation and
came up with point zero zero six three
percent error rate which is well with
intolerance and so i made very clear the
president because he was so fixated on
the asa report in the december 15
conversation that in fact
our investigation revealed that the
error rate was point zero zero six three
percent so that mr president's example
what people are telling you that is not
true
and that you cannot and should not be
relying on so that was one very explicit
one and i think you see that reflected
in my notes we went through a series of
others the truck driver who uh claimed
to have moved an entire tractor-trailer
of ballots from new york to pennsylvania
that was also incorrect
we did an investigation with the fbi
interview witnesses at the front end and
the back end
of that that trailers
transit from new york to pennsylvania we
looked at loading manifest we
interviewed witnesses including of
course the driver
and we knew it wasn't true
whether the driver believed or not was
never clear to me but it was just not
true so that was another one that i
tried to educate the president on
there were a series of others mostly in
swing states of course you want to talk
a great deal about georgia the state
forum arena video which he believed
for various reasons
was as he said it fraud staring you
right in the face were any of the
allegations he brought up found credible
did you find any of them credible
no
so during this conversation did did you
take handwritten notes directly quoting
the president
i did and to make it clear
attorney general rosen called me on my
government cell phone so they've been on
the phone with the president for some
time the president had a lot of these
allegations um i was
better versed in what the department had
done just because i had closer contact
with the investigations and the a.g
asked me to get on the call of course i
agreed
and i began taking notes
only because at the outset the president
made an allegation i had not heard i had
heard many of these things i knew many
of them were investigated
but when the president
at least when i came to the conversation
when he began speaking he brought up an
allegation i was completely unaware of
and of course that concerned us so i
simply reached out and grabbed a notepad
off my wife's nightstand and a pen and i
started jotting it down that had to do
with an allegation
that more than 200 000
votes were certified in the state of
pennsylvania that were not actually cast
sometimes the president would say was
205 sometimes he would say was 250 but
i'd not heard this before and i want to
get the allegation down clearly
so that we can look into it if
appropriate and that's why i started
taking those notes and then as the
conversation continued i just continued
to take the notes
let's take a look at the notes uh if we
could right now
uh as we can see on the screen
you actually quote president trump
asking where's doj just like we heard
him say in his first television
interview how did you respond to that
so both uh
the acting ag and i tried to explain to
the president on this occasion and on
several other occasions
that
justice department has a very important
very specific but very limited role in
these elections states run their
elections we are not quality control for
the states
we are obviously interested in and have
a mission that relates to criminal
conduct in relation to federal elections
we also have related civil rights
responsibilities so we do have an
important role
but the bottom line was if a state
ran their election in such a way that it
was defective
that is to the state or congress to
correct is not for the justice
department to step in
and i certainly understood the president
as a layman not understanding why the
justice department didn't have at least
a civil role
to step in and bring suit on behalf of
the american people
we tried to explain that to him the
american people do not constitute the
client for the united states justice
department the one and only client of
the united states justice department is
the united states government
the united states government does not
have standing as we were repeatedly told
by our internal teams olc led by steve
engel as well as the office of solicitor
general
researched it and gave us
um thorough clear opinions that we
simply did not have standing we tried to
explain that to the president on
numerous occasions
let's take a look at another one of your
notes
uh you also noted that mr rosen said to
mr trump quote doj can't and won't snap
its fingers and change the outcome of
the election how did the president
respond to that sir
he responded very quickly and said
essentially
that's not what i'm asking you to do
what i'm just asking you to do is just
say it was corrupt and leave the rest to
me and the republican congressman
so let's now put up the notes uh where
you where you quote the president
as you're speaking to that he said the
president
the president said just say the election
was corrupt
and leave the rest of me and the
republican congressman
so mr donahue that's a direct quote from
president trump correct that's an exact
quote from the president yes
the next note
shows that even the even
that the president kept pressing
even though he had been told that there
was no evidence of fraud
the president keeps saying that the
department was quote obligated to tell
people that this was an illegal corrupt
election
that's also an exact quote from the
president yes
let me just uh be clear did the
department find any evidence to conclude
that there was anything illegal or
corrupt about the 2020 election
there were isolated instances of fraud
none of them came close to calling into
question the outcome
of the election in any individual state
and how would you describe the
president's demeanor during that call
he was more agitated than he was on
december 15th
the the president throughout all of
these meetings and telephone
conversations was adamant that he had
won and that we were not doing our job
um but it did escalate over time until
ultimately the meeting on january 3rd
which was
the most extreme of the meetings and
conversations so i want to make sure we
don't gloss this over
just say it was corrupt
and leave the rest to us
the president wanted the top justice
department officials to declare that the
election was corrupt even though as he
knew
there was absolutely no evidence to
support that statement
the president didn't care about actually
investigating the facts he just wanted
the department of justice to put its
stamp of approval on the lies
who was going to help him well jeff
clark
mr rosen on christmas eve your first
official day as the acting attorney
general
president trump called you what did he
want to talk about
uh the same things he was talking about
publicly he he wanted to talk about that
he thought the uh the election had been
uh stolen or or was corrupt and that
there was widespread fraud and i had
told him that
our reviews had not shown that to be the
case
so uh
we had an extended discussion
probably 15 maybe 20 minutes something
like that
uh with with him
urging that the department of justice
should be doing more
with regard to election fraud
did he mention jeff clark's name
yes
it was just in passing he made
what i regarded as a peculiar reference
i don't remember the exact quote but it
was something about did i know jeff
clark or did i know who he was or
something like that
and i told him i did
and then the conversation just moved on
but when i i hung up
i was i was uh quizzical as to how does
the president even know
uh mr clark
i was not aware that they had ever met
or that the president had been involved
with any of the issues
in the civil division it was a bit of a
surprise when he brought his name up yes
so mr clark was the acting head of the
civil division and head of environmental
and natural resources division at the
department of justice
do either of those divisions have any
role whatsoever in investigating
election fraud sir no and and to my
awareness uh jeff clark had had no prior
involvement of any kind with regard to
the work that the department was doing
that attorney general barr has talked
about to this committee
so let's take a minute and explain why
the president mentioned jeff clark's
name to mr rosen here on christmas eve
on december 21st some republican members
of congress met with president trump in
the white house to talk about
overturning the 2020 election
let's hear representative marjorie
taylor-green talk about how this meeting
got set up
i was the only new member at the meeting
i called president trump on saturday and
and said we've got to have a meeting uh
there's many of us that feel like this
election has been stolen
so on the screen you'll see that
president trump's chief of staff mark
meadows tweeted about that meeting right
after it happened
he said quote several members of
congress just finished a meeting in the
oval office with president donald trump
preparing to fight back against mounting
evidence of voter fraud stay tuned
on the same day he met with these
republican members of congress president
trump called into a conservative
political convention and he used the
opportunity to pressure the department
of justice
to investigate his bogus
claims the problem is we need a party
that's going to fight and we have some
great congressmen and women that are
doing it and we have others some great
fighters but we won this in a landslide
they know it
and we need backing from like the
justice department and other people have
to finally step up
the select committee obtained records
from the national archives that show
that scott perry was one of the
congressmen who joined that meeting
we learned from white house records that
you'll now see on the screen
that the very next day representative
perry returned to the white house this
time he brought a justice department
official named jeffrey clark
representative perry provided the
following statement to his local tv
affiliate
he said quote
throughout the past four years i've
worked with assistant attorney general
clark on various legislative matters
when president trump asked if i would
make an introduction i obliged
but why jeff clark
let's hear mr giuliani explain the kind
of person that he and the president
wanted at the top of justice
i remember ever recommending to anybody
that um
mr clark
meaning jeffrey clark at doj
be given election related
responsibilities
you mean beyond the president
correct
well beyond the president i do recall
saying to people
that um
somebody should be put in charge of the
justice department
who isn't uh
frightened
of what's going to be done to their
reputation
um
because trust front was filled with
people like that
should put somebody that's not
frightened of what's going to be done to
their reputation mr donahue when you
told uh the president that you wouldn't
pursue baseless claims of fraud
was it because you were worried about
your reputation
no not at all
mr clark's name uh was also mentioned in
the white house in late december and
early january as described by a top aide
to mark meadows cassidy
was it your hutchinson that
representative perry was pushing for a
specific person to take over the
department he wanted mr clark mr jeff
clark to take over the department of
justice
mr rosen after your call with president
trump on december 24th you spoke with mr
clark on december 26th about his contact
with the president can you tell us about
that conversation
yes
um because i had been
quizzical about why his name had come up
i called him
and i uh tried to explore if he would
share
uh if there was something i ought to
know and after some back and forth
he acknowledged that shortly before
christmas
he had gone to a meeting in the oval
office with the president
that of course
surprised me
and i asked him how did that happen
and he was
defensive he said
it had been unplanned that he had been
talking to
uh someone he referred to as uh general
perry but i believe his congressman
perry
and that unbeknownst to him he was asked
to go to a meeting and he didn't know it
but it turned out it was at the oval he
found himself at the oval office
and uh and he was apologetic for that
and i said well you didn't tell me about
it it wasn't authorized and you didn't
even tell me after the fact
this is not not appropriate
but he was contrite and said it had been
inadvertent and it would not happen
again
and that if anyone asked him to go to
such a meeting he would notify rich
donohue and me
is there a policy that governs uh who
can have contact directly with the white
house yes
so across many administrations for for a
long period of time
there's a policy that uh particularly
with regard to criminal investigations
restricts at both the white house and
the justice department and
those more sensitive issues to the
highest ranks so for criminal matters
the policy for a long time has been that
only the attorney general and the deputy
attorney general from the doj side
can have conversations about criminal
matters with the white house
or
the attorney general the deputy attorney
general can authorize someone for a
specific item with their permission but
the idea is to make sure
that the top rung of the justice
department knows about it and is in the
thing to control it and make sure only
appropriate things are done mr ringo
from your perspective why is it
important to have a policy like mr rosen
just discussed
well it's critical that the department
of justice conducts its criminal
investigations free from either the
reality or any appearance of political
interference and so people can get in
trouble uh if people at the white house
are speaking with people at the
department and that's why the purpose of
these policies
is to keep these communications as
infrequent and at the highest levels as
possible
just to make sure that people who are
less careful about it who don't really
understand these implications such as mr
clark
don't run afoul uh of those contact
policies
thank you so the select committee
conducted an informal interview with the
white house counsel pat sipoloni and his
deputy pat philbin about their contact
with mr clark
though neither has yet agreed to sit for
transcribed and videotaped interviews
but pat sipoloni told the select
committee that he intervened when he
heard mr clark was meeting with the
president about legal matters without
his knowledge which was strictly against
white house policy
mr simpoloni and mr philbin like mr
rosen told mr clark to stand down and he
didn't
on the same day acting attorney general
rosen told mr clark to stop talking to
the white house
representative perry
was urging chief of staff mark meadows
to elevate clark within the department
of justice
you can now see on the screen behind me
a series of texts between representative
perry and mr meadows
they show that representative perry
requested that mr clark be elevated
within the department
representative perry tells mr meadows on
december 26 that quote
mark just checking in as time continues
to count down
11 days to january 6 and 25 days to
inauguration we've got to get going
representative perry followed up and
says quote
mark you should call jeff i just got off
the phone with him and he explained to
me why the principal deputy won't work
especially with the fbi they will view
it as not having the authority to
enforce what needs to be done
mr meadows responds with
i got it i think i understand
let me work on the deputy position
representative perry then texts roger
just sent you something on signal
just sent you an updated file
did you call jeff clark
mr donohue
representative perry called you the next
day
on december 27th who who told him to
call you
my understanding as the president did at
the outset of the call congressman perry
told me that he was calling at the best
of the president
what did what did he want to talk about
you want to talk about pennsylvania in
particular
he gave me some background about you
know why he in particular doesn't trust
the fbi and why the american people
don't necessarily trust the fbi
and then he went into some allegations
specific to pennsylvania
which included amongst others this
allegation that
the secretary of state had certified
more votes than were actually cast
did you uh direct the local uh the local
us attorney's office to investigate that
claim so mr perry said that he had a
great deal of information that
investigations had been done that there
was some sort of
forensic type report that would be
helpful to me
and i i didn't know congressman perry
had never heard him before this
conversation but i said sir if you've
got something that you think
is relevant to what the justice
department's mission is you should feel
free to send it to me i mean he did and
i was in route from new york to
washington i got it
i looked at it on my iphone obviously i
couldn't read the whole thing in that
in transit like that but i looked at it
to get a feel for what it was and then i
forwarded it to the united states
attorney for the western district
of pennsylvania did they get back to you
what did they conclude
scott brady looked at he was the western
district of pennsylvania u.s attorney
took him a couple days but
he got back in relatively short order
with a pretty clear explanation for why
there was no
foundation for concern the secretary of
state had not certified
more votes than were actually cast the
difference between the
5.25 that was actually certified by the
secretary of state and the 5 million
that was on a public-facing website was
that the information on the website was
incomplete because four counties had not
uploaded their data
so no credibility to that there was zero
to that right during that call did uh
scott perry mentioned mr clark and uh
what did he say about him if so
he did he mentioned mr clark um he said
something the effect of uh i think jeff
clark is great and i think he's the kind
of guy who could get in there and do
something about this stuff
and this was coming on the heels of the
president
having mentioned mr clark
in the
afternoon call
earlier that day
i'd like to yield to the gentlewoman uh
from wyoming vice chair cheney
uh thank you very much uh mr kinser
thank the gentleman for yielding as we
discussed earlier at the center of mr
clark's plan to undo president trump's
election loss
was a letter mr donohue on december 28th
mr clark emailed you and mr rosen a
draft letter that he wanted you to sign
and send to georgia state officials
you testified that this could have quote
grave constitutional consequences mr
donahue can you tell us what you meant
by that
well i had to read uh both the email and
the attached letter twice to make sure i
really understood what he was proposing
because it
was so extreme to me i had a hard time
getting my head around it initially
but i read it and i did understand it
for what he intended and
i i had to sit down and serve compose
what i thought was an appropriate
response i actually initially went next
door to the acting ag's office but he
was not there
we were both on that email i knew we
would both have probably a very similar
reaction to it he was not in his office
so i returned to my office and i sat
down to draft a response because i
thought it was very important to give a
prompt response rejecting this out of
hand
um there were
in my response i explained a number of
reasons this is not the department's
role
to
suggest or dictate to state legislatures
how they should select their electors
but more importantly this was not based
on fact this was actually contrary to
the facts
as developed by department
investigations over the last several
weeks and months
so i responded to that and for the
department to insert itself
into the political process this way i
think would have had great consequences
for the country
it may very well have spiraled us into a
constitutional crisis
and i wanted to make sure that he
understood the gravity of the situation
because he didn't seem to really
appreciate it
and what was mr clark's reaction when
you uh
sent this email to him
he didn't respond directly to the email
but we met shortly after that after i
sent the email
the acting age returned i went to his
office he had just read it he had a very
similar reaction to me he was
exasperated and he told me that he had
told one of his administrative
assistants to get
jeff clark up here we want to talk to
him face to face about this and so the
three of us then had a meeting
probably around 1800 that night in the
deputy attorney general's conference
room
and one of the things that you said to
mr clark is quote what you are doing is
nothing less than the united states
justice department meddling in the
outcome of a presidential election and i
assume you conveyed that to him as well
in your meeting that evening yes in
those very words it was a very
contentious meeting but um yes that was
said amongst other things
um
and despite this contentious meeting and
your strong reaction to the letter um
did mr clark continue to push his
concept in the coming days
he did yes
we had subsequent meetings and
conversations
the acting ag probably had more contact
with him than i did
but between the 28th and the second when
we had another in-person meeting
he clearly continued to move down this
path
he began calling witnesses and
apparently conducting investigations of
his own
and uh he got a briefing from
dni about
purported foreign intelligence
interference
um and
we thought perhaps once it was explained
to him that there was no basis for that
part of his concern
that he would retreat
but instead he doubled down and said
well okay so there's no foreign
interference
i still think there are enough
allegations out there that we should go
ahead and send this letter which shocked
me even more than the initial one
because you would think after a couple
days of looking at this
he like we would have come to the same
conclusion that it was completely
unfounded
and when you learned that he had been
calling witnesses and conducting
investigations on his own did you
confront him yes
and uh what was his reaction
got very defensive um
you know as i said there were a series
of conversations through that week i
certainly remember very specifically the
conversation in the meeting on
january 2nd
that got even more confrontational
but he was defensive and
you know similar to his earlier reaction
when i said this is nothing less than
justice department meddling in an
election
his reaction was i think a lot of people
have meddled in this election
and so we kind of clung to that
and then
spewed out some of these theories
you
so
so
so
the committee will be in order
the chair recognizes the gentleman from
illinois
thank you mr chairman
as chairman around the time mr clark was
pushing for the department to send the
georgia letter
the president and his supporters were
pressuring the justice department to
take other actions to change the outcome
of the 2020 election
mr engel uh or you were the head of the
office of legal counsel can you first
off explain your role what is that
sure
one of the attorney general's most
important responsibilities is to provide
the legal advice to the president and to
the executive branch
as a practical matter given the
responsibilities of the attorney general
the assistant attorney general for the
office of legal counsel
exercises that uh that job on a
day-to-day basis and so
uh in addition uh the head of olc often
functions as a general counsel
essentially to the attorney general
uh and so is often you know the chief
legal advisor to the ag as well as you
know the white house and the executive
branch more broadly so given that role
can you kind of describe your
relationship with the president
well i you know in connection with my
role at olc
over the course of my tenure there there
were a number of instances in which
uh folks at the white house would would
seek to bring me in to provide
legal advice
to the president
sometimes discussing the legal options
that could be pursued among various
politics to reach various policy
objectives sometimes to advise the
president that
a course of action that they had been
discussing was not legally available
so i want to ask you about uh two things
the president asked you and the
department to do the first is reflected
in this email that we're going to put on
the screen
the president sent a draft lawsuit to be
filed by the department in the supreme
court
he wanted you mr rosen and mr sipoloni
specifically to review it you and the
department opposed filing it
we see on the screen here that the talk
the talking points that you actually
drafted on that so you stated that there
is no legal basis to bring this lawsuit
uh anyone who thinks otherwise simply
doesn't know the law much less the
supreme court
uh why was this the department's
position
well i mean i think it was
the memo sort of speaks to this but
essentially this was a draft lawsuit
that apparently was prepared by people
outside the department uh it would be
styled as brought by the united states
and by the the acting solicitor general
as an original jurisdiction matter in
the supreme court
uh it was a meritless lawsuit that was
not something that the department could
or or would bring you know somebody
obviously prepared it to hand it to the
president and he forwarded it on for our
review but
that memo explains why the department of
justice as mr donahue said earlier
doesn't have any standing
to bring such a lawsuit the lawsuit
would have been untimely the states had
chosen their electors the electors have
been certified they've cast their votes
they've been sent to washington d.c
neither georgia nor any of the other
states on december 28th or whenever this
was was in a position to change those
votes the essentially the election had
happened the only thing that hadn't
happened was the formal counting of the
votes uh and so obviously you know the
person who drafted this lawsuit didn't
really understand uh in my view you know
the law and or how the supreme court
works or the department so it's just not
something we were going to do and the
acting attorney general asked me to
prepare a memo with talking points so
that he could explain our reasons when
he spoke with president about this so
would you say it was an unusual request
certainly did you say the the request
that the department file a lawsuit from
uh drafted by outside lawyers was
certainly an unusual request
there was another issue you were asked
to look into in mid-december did the
white house ask attorney general barr to
consider whether a special counsel could
be appointed to look into election fraud
issues
yes um i mean the the
i think the president was probably vocal
at the time that he believed that
special counsel was something that
should be considered to look into
uh election fraud and there is a
specific you know request where the
attorney general sought my legal advice
in in the middle of december and what
was your conclusion what conclusion did
you so this this request was whether the
uh whether the attorney general could
appoint as a special counsel uh a state
attorney general uh to conduct an
investigation i mean as a legal matter
under federal law the attorney general
actually has fairly wide discretion to
delegate prosecutorial authority
including to
state prosecutors which happens to
assist the department
uh you know and not uncommonly obviously
a state attorney general at exercising
prosecutorial authority on behalf of
the department of justice would be
fairly uncommon
when we looked at the issue what we saw
is actually that the state law the state
was louisiana
that the state
law precluded the louisiana attorney
general from accepting any position any
official position
on behalf of the united states
government so that that answered the
question that it was not legally
available so during your time at the
department was there ever any basis to
appoint a special counsel to investigate
president trump's election fraud claims
well neither attorney general bar nor
acting attorney general rosen did
appoint a special counsel um you would
appoint the special counsel when
uh the
department when there's a basis for an
investigation and the department
essentially has a conflict of interest
it's important to get someone who's
independent outside the department to
handle such an investigation
neither attorney general bar nor acting
attorney general rosa never believed
that that was appropriate or necessary
in this case in fact attorney general
bar had already told the president that
there was no need for this special
counsel he actually stated that publicly
and we'll see that here in a video from
december 21st
to the extent that
there's an
investigation i think that it's being
handled responsibly and professionally
currently within the the department and
to this point i have not seen a reason
to appoint a
special counsel and i have no plan to do
so before i leave so remember that
december 21st was the same day president
trump met with republican members at the
white house to strategize about how to
overturn the election while his attorney
general is out telling the public again
that there was no widespread evidence of
election fraud
and yet two days later we have president
trump tweeting again publicly pressuring
the department to appoint a special
counsel he said quote after seeing the
massive voter fraud in the 2020
presidential election i disagree with
anyone that thinks a strong fast and
fair special counsel is not needed
immediately
this was the most corrupt election in
the history of our country and it must
be closely examined
the select committee's investigation
revealed that president trump went as
far as to promise the job of special
counsel
to now discredited former trump campaign
lawyer sydney powell at a late night
meeting on december 18th
and then on friday he had asked me to be
a special counsel to address the
election
issues
and to collect evidence
and
he was extremely frustrated with
the lack of i would call it law
enforcement
by any of the government agencies that
are supposed to act to protect the rule
of law in our republic
so let's think here what would a special
counsel do
with only days to go until election
certification it wasn't to investigate
anything
an investigation led by a special
counsel
would just create an illusion of
legitimacy
and provide fake cover for those who
would want to object
including those who stormed the capitol
on january 6th
all of president trump's plans for the
justice department were being rebuffed
by mr rosen mr donohue mr engel and
others
the president became desperate entering
into the new year with january 6 fast
approaching
president trump rushed back early from
mar-a-lago on december 31st and called
an emergency meeting with the
department's leadership
here's mr donahue describing the last
minute meeting held at the white house
on new year's eve
the president was a little more
agitated than he had been on the meeting
in the meeting on the 15th
um
he discussed a variety of
election matters
he did say
this sounds like the kind of thing that
would want an appointment of a special
counsel
there was a point at which the president
said
something about
why don't you guys seize machines
mr rosen the president asked you to
seize voting machines from state
governments what was your response to
that request
we had we had seen nothing improper with
regard to the voting machines
and i told them that the
the
real experts at that had been at dhs and
they had briefed us
that
they had looked at it and that there was
nothing wrong with the voting machines
and so
that was not something it was
appropriate to do
there would be no factual basis to seize
machines
mr donnie i don't think there was legal
authority either
yeah mr donahue can you explain what the
president did
after he was told that the justice
department would not seize voting
machines
president was very agitated by the
acting attorney general's response um
and uh to the extent that uh machines
and and the technology was being
discussed
the acting attorney general said that
the
dhs
department of homeland security has
expertise in machines
and certifying them and making sure that
the states are operating them properly
and since dhs had been mentioned the
president yelled out to his secretary
get ken cuccinelli on the phone
um and she did in very short order mr
cuccinelli was on the phone he was the
number two at dhs at the time
i was on the speaker phone
and the president essentially said ken
i'm sitting here with the acting
attorney general he just told me it's
your job to seize machines and you're
not doing your job
and mr cuccinelli responded
mr rosa did you ever tell the president
that the department of homeland security
could seize voting machines
no certainly not
mr donohue during this meeting did the
president tell you that he would remove
you and mr rosen because you weren't
declaring there was election fraud
toward the end of the meeting
the president
again was getting very agitated and he
said people tell me i should just get
rid of both of you i should just remove
you
and um make a change in the leadership
put jeff clark in maybe something will
finally get done
um and i responded as i think i had
earlier in the december uh 27th call mr
president you should have the leadership
that you want but understand the united
states justice department functions on
facts evidence and law and those are not
going to change so you can have whatever
leadership you want but the department's
position is not going to change
the president's white house counsel pat
cibolone was also present do you
remember what his position was
that was very supportive uh pat
simpoloni throughout these conversations
was extremely supportive of the justice
department he was consistent
i think he had an impossible job at that
point but he did it well and he always
sided with the justice department in
these discussions
so let's pause for a second it's new
year's eve
president trump talking about seizing
voting machines and making the same
demands that had already been shot down
by former attorney general barr on at
least three occasions and by mr rosen
and mr donahue on multiple other
occasions
claim after claim knocked down
but the president didn't care
the next day chief of staff mark meadows
sent a flurry of emails to you mr rosen
asking that the department look into a
new set of allegations
we're going to put those emails here on
the screen
here we see three requests made on
january 1st
one email is a request from mr meadows
to you mr rosen to send jeff clark to
fulton county what did you what did you
do with this request
well really really nothing certainly
didn't send mr clark to fulton county
but
that email
was the first corroboration i had seen
of mr clark had told me at that point
that the president was considering
making the change by monday uh january
4th
so mr meadows email
was something of a corroboration that
there were discussions going on that i
had been
not been informed about by mr clark or
anybody
else interesting the second request uh
that you have is to have the department
of justice lawyers investigate
allegations of fraud related to new
mexico
mr rosen did you have concern about
these emails
yes uh uh really two concerns about that
one one was that it was coming from a
campaign or political party
and it was really not our role to
function as as uh
you know an arm of any campaign for any
party or any campaign that wasn't our
role
uh and that's part of why i had been
unwilling to meet with mr giuliani or
any of the the campaign uh people before
and
the other part was it was another one of
these it was another one
mr donohue did you watch this video
i did congressman how long was the video
approximately 20 minutes let's just take
a look at a excerpt of that video if we
may
what's being said out of rome out of
italy is that this was done in the u.s
embassy
that there was a certain state
department guy
whose name i don't know
uh yet i guess this is probably going to
come out in italy at some point
and he was the mastermind not the
mastermind but the um
but anyway the guy running the operation
of changing the votes
and that he was doing this in
conjunction with some support from mi6
the cia
and
this leonardo group
mr donahue what was your reaction when
you watched that entire 20 minute video
i emailed the acting attorney general
and i said pure insanity which was my
impression of
the video which
was patently absurd
mr rosen you were asked by mr meadows uh
to meet with mr johnson who is the
person in that video
what was your reaction to that request
so
ordinarily i'd get an email like this
and there was no phone call it would
just you know come over the transom but
this one he he called me mr meadows
and asked me to meet with mr johnson
and i told him
this whole thing about
italy had been debunked
and that should be the end of that and i
certainly wasn't going to meet with with
this person
and he initially seemed to accept that i
uh he said you know why why won't you
meet with him i said because if if he
has real evidence which this video
doesn't show he can walk into an fbi
field office anywhere in the united
states there's 55 of them
he said okay
but then he called me me back a few
minutes later
and complained
and said um i didn't tell you but
this this fellow johnson is working with
rudy giuliani and mr giuliani is really
offended that you think they have to go
to a fbi field office that's insulting
so couldn't couldn't you just have the
fbi or or you meet with these guys
and
by then i was
somewhat agitated
and told them that there was no way on
earth that i was going to do that
uh i wasn't going to meet with mr
johnson i certainly wasn't going to meet
with mr giuliani i made that clear
repeatedly
and
so that's that's the end of that you
know don't don't raise this with me
again
and so uh because mr donohue and i had
been in exchanging uh uh our views about
this
it was yeah 7 13 on a friday night of
new year's day
i had run out of patience and i sent the
email that you're you're talking about
where uh
i made pretty clear that i had no
interest in
doing anything further with this
just to button this up mr donahue did
you receive a follow-up call from a
department of defense official about
this conspiracy
i did i believe it was that same day
can you give a details on that at all
i received a telephone call from uh cash
patel who i know was a dod official at
that time worked for um i believe acting
secretary defense miller
um and he didn't know much about it he
basically said uh do you know anything
about this italy thing and what this is
all about
and i
informed him that the chief of staff had
raised the issue with us in his office
on december 29th
that we had looked into it a little bit
we had run the name that was provided to
us by the chief of staff i learned that
that individual was in custody in italy
he had been arrested for a cyber offense
of some sort in italy the allegation was
that he had been exfiltrating data from
his company he was either an employee
or a contractor of that company he was
in custody
that the whole thing was very very murky
at best and the video was absurd
um but that we read the department we're
not gonna have anything to do with it
and um
dod should make up its own mind as to
what they're going to do but
i made it clear to him that i didn't
think was anything worth pursuing she
called the video absurd and and despite
the absurdity of that conspiracy theory
uh we learned that mr meadows discussed
it frequently in the white house and mr
meadows didn't let the matter go uh the
request went from the department of
justice to the secretary of defense
christopher miller as you'll hear
secretary miller actually reached out to
a high ranking official based in italy
to follow up on this claim
to ask for him was can you call out the
defense attitude rome and find out what
the heck's going on because i'm getting
all these weird crazy reports probably
the guy in the ground is more than
anything
select committee confirmed that a call
was actually placed by secretary miller
to the attache in italy to investigate
the claim that italian satellites were
switching votes from trump to biden
this is one of the best examples of the
links to which the pres president trump
would go to stay in power
scouring the internet to support his
conspiracy theories shown here
as he told mr donahue in that december
27th call quote you guys may not be
following the internet the way i do
president trump's efforts to this point
had failed stonewalled by mr rosen and
mr donahue president trump had only one
option he needed to make clark acting
attorney general
mr rosen during a january second meeting
with mr clark did you confront him again
about his contact with the president and
if so can you describe that
so
um at this point mr clark had told us
that
the president had asked him to consider
whether he would be willing to replace
me
supposedly on a timetable by monday
the
and so uh
i had told mr clark i thought he was
making a colossal error in judgment but
i also hope to persuade him
uh
to
be more rational and to
understood what we had understood that
there's not a factual basis for the
fraud assertions that are being made
so at this meeting mr donohue and i
met with mr clark
and i guess my my hopes were
disappointed and that mr clark
continued to express view that he
thought there was
uh fraud even though he had not been a
participant in the department's review
of that
and that he was
dissatisfied that
we knew what we were doing
so
but he had acknowledged
that he had had further i don't know if
it was meeting or phone calls or what
but further discussion with the
president
despite having
you know a week earlier said that if he
he wouldn't do that and if he did he if
he got an invitation to do that he would
let rich donahue or me know
so
uh
we had a it was a contentious meeting
where we were chastising him that
he was insubordinate he was out of line
he had not honored his own
representations of what he would do
and
he raised again
that he thought that letter
uh should go out
and we were not receptive to that
can you tell you in that the president
had offered him the job of acting
attorney general
that was a day later on this on the
second he he said that the president had
asked him to let him know if he'd be
willing to take it
subsequently he told me that uh on this
on sunday the third he told me that the
timeline had moved up and that the
president had offered him the job and
that he was accepting it
was asked about that what was your
reaction to that
well uh
you know on the one hand i wasn't going
to accept being fired by my subordinate
so i wanted to talk to the the president
directly
um with regard to
uh the reason for that is
i wanted to try to convince the
president not to go down
the wrong path that mr clark seemed to
be advocating
and it wasn't about me there's only 17
days left in the administration at that
point i would have been perfectly
content to have either the gentleman in
my left or right replace me if if
anybody wanted to do that
but i did not want for the department of
justice
to be put in a posture where it would be
doing things that were not consistent
with the truth
we're not consistent with its own
appropriate role or we're not consistent
with the constitution
so
i did four things as soon as mr clark
left my office on on that sunday the
third
number one i called mark meadows and
said i need to see the president right
away he was agreeable and set up a
meeting uh for 6 15 at that sunday so
about two hours
away
two i called pat zippoloni the white
house counsel
told him what was going on and he said
he would
go into the white house to make sure he
was at the meeting and he would be
supporting the justice department's
position as he had been doing
consistently
three i called steve engel who was i was
at the department it was a sunday but
there had been some reasons i needed to
be there
mr engel i called at home and asked him
that he would come in and go to the
meeting which he did that proved to be
quite uh helpful
and then number four
i asked rich donahue
and pat hovakimian who had previously
been my chief of staff
to get the department's senior
leadership on a call and let them know
what was going on
and which they did
and then
uh eric hirschman called me
to tell me that he was going to go to
the meeting and that he would be
supporting the department of justice
position as well
so i knew
that the meeting was on course and that
i would have
a number of people supportive of the
department of justice's approach
and not supportive of mr clark's
approach
did mr clark ask you to continue to stay
at the department
at that sunday meeting
uh when he told me that he would be
replacing me
uh
he he said that he had asked to see me
alone because usually he had met with me
and mr donohue
because he thought it would be
appropriate in light of what was
happening to at least offer me that i
could stay on as his deputy
i thought that was preposterous
i told him that was
nonsensical and and that
there's no universe where i was going to
do that to stay on and support someone
else doing
things that were not consistent with
what i thought should be done
so uh
i didn't accept that offer if i could
put it that way
and during that meeting did mr clark ask
you to sign the georgia letter
that was on the the saturday meeting uh
january 2nd that mr donahue and i had
with him
he again raised with both of us that
that he wanted us to i have both to sign
that letter actually so in that meeting
did mr clark say he would turn down the
president's offer if you reversed your
position and signed the letter yes
did mr clark
so you still refuse to sign and send
that letter i take it that that's right
uh i i think mr donohue and i were both
uh very consistent that there was no way
we were going to sign that letter and it
didn't matter
what mr clark's you know proposition was
in terms of of his own activities we
were not going to sign that letter as
long as
we were in charge of the justice
department
thank you for that by the way mr donahue
were you expecting to have to attend a
meeting at the white house on on sunday
january third
no um as the acting agency indicated uh
we had a meeting that afternoon that
related to preparations for january 6th
so i was at the department but i had no
expectation of leaving the department it
was a sunday afternoon
and i was there in civilian close
as we both work
and expected to have that meeting do
some other work but i had no expectation
of going to the white house that day so
let's ask so prior to that oval office
meeting did you set up a conference call
with senior leadership at the department
and if so tell us about that call
yes so uh obviously it was a bit of a
scramble that afternoon to prepare for
the oval office meeting um we had
discussed on several occasions
the acting attorney general and i
whether we should expand the circle of
people who knew what was going on it was
very important that steve angle know and
that's why i reached out to steve
on december 28th because if
mr rosen were removed from the seat and
the president did not immediately
appoint someone else to serve as
attorney general just by function of the
department's um chain of succession mr
angle would be in the seat we wanted to
make sure he knew what was going on
should that occur
so
the three of us knew we also brought
brought had hovakimian in so the four of
us knew
but no one else aside from jeff clark of
course knew what was going on until late
that sunday afternoon
we chose to keep a close hold because we
didn't want to create
concern or panic in the justice
department leadership
but at this point
i asked the
acting ag what else can i do to help
prepare for this meeting at the oval
office and he said
you and pat should get the aags on the
phone and it's time to let them know
what's going on let's find out what they
may do
if there's a change in leadership
because that will help inform the
conversation at the oval office at
hovakimian subsequently set up that
meeting we got most not all but most of
the aag's on the phone
we very quickly explained to them what
the situation was
i told them
i don't need an answer from you
right now i don't need an answer in this
phone call but if you have an answer i
need it in the next few minutes so call
me email me text me
whatever it is
if you know what you would do if jeff
clark is put in charge of the department
and immediately eric drybun who was the
aag of the civil rights division said i
don't need to think about it there's no
way i'm staying
and then the other aegs began to chime
in
in turn and all effects essentially said
they would leave they would resign in
mass if the president made that change
in the department leadership
incredible i'd like to look at the
assistant attorney generals on the
screen
uh if we can pull that up have their
pictures
did every assistant attorney general you
spoke to as you said agreed to resign
uh
macon del rahim was not on the call only
because we had some difficulty reaching
him but yes the other people on the
screen were on the call and all without
hesitation said that they would resign
so as part of the select committee's
investigation we found that well mr
rosen mr donahue and mr engel were
preparing for their meeting at the white
house
jeff clark and the president were in
constant
communication beginning at 7 am
white house call logs obtained by the
committee show that by 4 19 pm on
january 3rd
the white house had already begun
referring to mr clark as the acting
attorney general
as far as the white house was concerned
mr clark was already at the top of the
justice department
two hours later doj leadership arrived
at the white house
the select committee interviewed every
person who was inside the room
that
was inside the room during this sunday
evening oval office meeting
mr cibolone told the committee that he
was quote unmistakably angry during the
meeting and that he along with eric
hirschman and mr donohue
forcefully challenged mr clark to
produce evidence of his election fraud
theories
mr rosen can you describe how that
meeting started
yes
so um after some preliminaries so we we
uh mr meadows had ushered us all in and
then he left
uh so mr cipolloni did some
introductions and things so after some
preliminaries
the president turned to me
and he said
well one thing we know is you rosen you
aren't going to do anything you don't
even
agree with the
claims of election fraud
and this other guy at least might do
something
and then i said
mr president
you're right that i'm not going to allow
the justice department to do anything to
try to overturn the election that's true
but the reason for that is because
that's what's consistent with the facts
and the law and that's what's uh
required under the constitution so
that's the right answer and a good thing
for the country
and therefore i submit it's the right
thing for you mr president
and that kicked off uh another two hours
of discussion in which everyone in the
room
was in one way or another making
different points but uh supportive my
approach for the justice department and
critical
of mr clark
so at some point mr donahue comes in the
room can you explain what led to him
coming in the room oh uh i forgot about
that
so initially um
in part i think because he was
underdressed
we and we had not arranged we had not
yet told the president that he was going
to come in
uh the white house had had a list of who
would be there that did include mr engel
and the white house counsel and the
deputy council mr hershman
um we went in and then we told the
president
you know maybe 10 minutes into the
meeting or something i forget how far in
mr donahue was outside and he said we'll
bring him in and then then mr donahue
came in and joined the meeting so mr
donohue you you enter that room can you
set the uh scene for us and describe the
tone you walked into
uh
yes but if i could just back up one
moment congressman because she put the
pictures up on the screen of the aag's i
just want to make clear one of the ag's
who's not on the screen was john demers
john was the national security division
aag
john was on the call but i prefaced the
call by saying john
we need you to stay in place national
security is too important we need to
minimize a disruption
whether you resign is entirely up to you
obviously you will respect your decision
either way but i'm asking you please
stay in place and he did so i don't want
to uh leave the impression that he was
not willing to resign because i think he
was thank you so with regard to entering
the oval office i was sitting in the
hallway
um
an administrative assistant passed by
she asked me are you supposed to be in
this meeting with the president i said
no i'm simply here in case questions
come up that other people don't have the
answer to
and she walked away and then came back
probably 30 seconds later and said the
president wants you in the meeting
i proceeded into the oval office
i took probably two three steps in and i
stopped because i was as the ag said not
exactly properly attired i was wearing
jeans and muddy boots and an army
t-shirt
and i
never would arrive in the oval office
this way i said mr president i apologize
i'm sorry
i didn't know he's going to be here and
he said no no no just come in come in
come in and so i i went in i attempted
to take a seat on one of the couches or
behind the chairs right in front of the
president's desk
and he said oh no no no you're going to
be up here
and everyone kind of laughed and
they
moved the chairs a little bit
somewhere from the white house council's
office picked up a spare chair and put
it directly in front of the president
and i took that seat
was it was there discussion about mr
clark can you can you
kind of enlighten some of what that
discussion was yes so the conversation
at this point had moved beyond the
specific allegations whether it was
state farm arena or antrim county or
pennsylvania or whatever we had
discussed those repeatedly and
the congress that was backdrop to the
conversation but the conversation at
this point was really about whether the
president should remove
jeff rosen and replace him with jeff
clark
and
everyone in the room i think understood
that that meant that letter would go out
um
so
that was the focus it was about a two
and a half hour meeting after i entered
and so there were discussions about
the pros and cons of doing that
um early on the president said
what do i have to lose
and
it was actually a good opening because i
said mr president you have a great deal
to lose
and i began to explain to him what he
had to lose
um and what the country had to lose and
what the department had to lose and this
was not in anyone's best interest
that conversation went on for some time
uh everyone essentially chimed in with
their own thoughts all of which were
consistent about how damaging this would
be
to the country to the department to the
administration to him personally
um
and
at some point the conversation turned to
whether jeff clark was even qualified
competent to run the justice department
which in my mind he clearly was not
and it was a heated conversation i
thought it was useful to point out to
the president that jeff clark
simply didn't have the the skills the
ability and the experience to run the
department
and so i said mr president you're
talking about putting
a man in that seat who has never tried a
criminal case who's never conducted a
criminal investigation he's telling you
that he's going to take charge of the
department 115 000 employees including
the entire fbi
and turn the place on a dime and conduct
nationwide criminal investigations that
will produce results in a matter of days
it's impossible it's absurd it's not
going to happen and it's going to fail
he has never been in front
of
a trial jury a grand jury he's never
even been to chris ray's office
i said at one point if you walked into
chris ray's office
when would you know how to get there and
two if you got there would you even know
who you are
do you really think that the fbi is
going to suddenly start following your
orders it's not going to happen he's not
competent
and that's the the point at which um
mr clark tried to defend himself by
saying well i've been involved in very
significant civil and environmental
litigation i've argued many appeals and
appellate courts and things of that
nature and then i
pointed out that yes he was an
environmental lawyer and
i didn't think that was appropriate
background to be ruined in the united
states justice department did anybody in
there support mr clark no one
mr rosen
it was you he was going to replace so
what was your view about the president's
plan to appoint mr clark well well well
as i alluded to earlier
the issue really wasn't about me
it was
it would have been fine as i said to
have had rich donahue replace me i would
have said great i i get 17 days vacation
or something
but uh the issue was
the
use of the justice department and it's
just so important that the justice
department
uh adhere
to the facts and the law that's what
it's there to do
and
that's what
uh our constitutional role was
and so if the justice department
gets out of the role that it's supposed
to play
that's really bad for our country and i
don't have a simpler way to say that and
when you damage our fundamental
institutions
it's not easy to repair them
so i thought
this was a really important issue to try
to make sure that the justice department
was able to stay on the right course
mr donahue did
did you eventually tell the president
that mass resignations would occur if he
installed mr clark and what the
consequences would be
yes so this was in line with the
president saying well i have to lose um
and um
along those lines he said so suppose i
do this suppose i replace him
jeff rosen with him jeff clark
what would you do and i said mr
president we resigned immediately i'm
not working one minute for this guy um
who i just
declared was completely incompetent and
so
the president immediately turned to uh
to mr engel and he said steve you
wouldn't resign would you and he said
absolutely i would mr president you
leave me no choice
and and then i said and we're not the
only ones no one cares if we resign if
steve and i go that's fine it doesn't
matter but i'm telling you what's going
to happen you're going to lose your
entire department leadership every
single aag will walk out on you your
entire department leadership will walk
out within hours
and i don't know what happens after that
i don't know what the united states
attorneys are going to do
we have
us attorneys in districts across the
country
and
my guess would be that many of them
would have resigned
and that would then have led to
resignations across the department in
washington
and i said mr president within
24 48 72 hours you could have hundreds
and hundreds of resignations of the
leadership of your entire justice
department because of your actions
what's that going to say about you
wow mr angle what was
can you describe what your reaction was
to that
yeah no i think when the president my
recollection is that when the president
turned to me and said steve you you
wouldn't leave would you uh i said mr
president i've been with you through
four attorneys general including two
acting's attorney general uh but i
couldn't be part of this uh and then the
other thing that i said was that
uh you know
look
i
all anyone is gonna sort of think about
when they see this no one is going to
read this letter
all anyone is going to think
is that you went through two attorneys
general in two weeks until you found the
environmental guy to sign this thing and
so the story is not going to be that the
department of justice has found
massive corruption that would have
changed the results of the election it's
going to be the disaster
of jeff clarke and i think at that point
pascipoloni said yeah this is a
murder-suicide pact this letter
and i would i would know to congressman
that it was in this part of the
conversation where steve
uh pointed out that jeff clark would be
left
leading a graveyard
and that
that comment clearly had an impact on
the president the leadership will be
gone jeff clark will be left leading a
graveyard
again the premise that which as mr
donahue has said but that mr clark could
come in
uh and take over the department of
justice and do something different was
just an absurd premise and all he was
doing mr clark by putting himself
forward was
blowing himself up and you know if the
president were to have gone that course
uh you know would have been a grievous
error for the president as well
mrs boloni the white house counsel told
the committee that mr ingalls response
had a noticeable impact on the president
that this was a turning point
uh in the conversation
mr donahue towards the end of this
meeting did the president ask you what
was going to happen to mr clark
he did when we finally got to the i
would say the last 15 minutes the
meeting the president's decision was
apparent he announced it
jeff clark tried to scrape his way back
and
ask the president to reconsider
um the president doubled down said no
i've made my decision that's it we're
not going to do it
and then he turned to me and said
so what happens to him now
meeting mr clark and he understood that
mr clark reported to me
and i i didn't initially understand the
question i i said mr president and he
said are you going to fire him
and i said i don't have the authority to
fire him he's the senate confirmed
assistant attorney general
and he said well who has the authority
to fire him and i said only you do sir
and he said well i'm not gonna fire him
i said all right well then we should all
go back to work
did you get a call from the president
later that night
i did um i know probably 90 minutes
later or something like that what was
that about
um the president at this at this point
we left the white house
recommending at the department i left
the department i was back in my
apartment
my cell phone rang it was the president
and he had information about a truck
supposedly full of shredded ballots in
georgia
that was in the custody of an ice agent
whose name he had
i told him that ice was part of
department homeland security
um i had heard about this if department
of homeland security needed our
assistance we of course would provide it
but it was really up to dhs to make a
call if their agent was involved and he
said fine
i understand can you just make sure that
ken meaning ken cuccinelli knows about
this
i said fine i would pass that along to
him i eventually contacted
ken cuccinelli later that evening and i
said this is what the president told me
if you guys have anything you think
should be brought to our attention let
me know and he said thank you and that
was it
mr cipolloni left the meeting convinced
the president would not appoint mr clark
but he didn't think the president had
actually accepted the truth about the
election
sure enough all the same debunked
theories appeared in his speech at the
ellipse three days later
in the state of arizona over 36 000
ballots were illegally cast by
non-citizens 11
600 more ballots and votes were counted
more than there were actual voters you
see that
in wisconsin
corrupt democrat-run cities
deployed more than 500 illegal unmanned
unsecured drop boxes
which collected a minimum of 91 000
unlawful votes
mr donahue mr rosen mr engel and others
stopped president trump's efforts at
least temporarily
yet the message president trump and his
republican allies pushed throughout
december
made its way to his supporters anyway
and they kept up the pressure campaign
on the way to storming the capitol on
january 6.
mr rosen were you at the department of
justice on january 6th
yes i was there all day
once the capital was under attack i
understand that you communicated with
fellow cabinet members and capitol hill
leadership can you tell us who you spoke
to
yeah i was basically on the phone
virtually non-stop all day some calls
with our own doj folks
some with cabinet counterparts uh at dhs
and and uh defense and the interior
some with senior white house officials
and with
a number of congressional leaders
uh
i received calls from speaker pelosi
from leader mccarthy
from
leader schumer
believes
leader mcconnell's chief of staff called
a number of other members of congress uh
as well
and the you know the basic thrust of the
calls with the members of congress was
there's a you know dire situation here
and can you help and i reported to them
that we were on a very urgent basis
sending help from the department uh
we we
wound up sending over 500 agents and
officers from
fbi atf and the us marshals to assist
with uh restoring order at the capitol
so uh had a number of calls as i say it
was more or less non-stop all afternoon
you speak to the vice president that day
yes twice
the
no please go ahead well i was gonna say
the the first call was a one-on-one
discussion
somewhat akin to the congressional
leadership calls uh
updating him on what we were doing to
assist and the
second call was a conference call around
seven o'clock
with the vice president congressional
leaders senior white house staff some
other cabinet officials
to address that order appeared to be
close to being restored or restored but
security still being determined and the
question being what time could the
congress reassemble
and uh
the answer was eight o'clock and
thankfully congress did reassemble and
complete its constitutional duty there
was one highlight of that second call
with the vice president which is mr
donahue had gone to the rotunda of the
capitol to be able to give firsthand
account and was able to tell the the
folks on the call including the vice
president
that
we thought 8 o'clock would work
did you speak to the president on
january 6
no i spoke to a number of senior white
house officials but not the
president mr donohue on january 6
we know
from mr rosen that you helped in the
effort to reconvene joint session the
joint session is that correct
yes
sir we see here in a video that we're
going to play now
you arriving with your security detail
to help secure the capitol
mr donohue 30 minutes after you arrived
to the capitol did you lead a briefing
for the vice president
uh exactly what the time frame was but
uh i did
participate the call and participate in
briefing the vice president as well as a
congressional leadership that night yes
now would you conduct that call at
i was in an office um
i'm not entirely sure where it was my
detail found it because the acoustics
and the rotunda were such that it wasn't
really conductive to having a call so
they found an office we went to that
office and i believe i participated two
phone calls when in 1800 and went 1900
that night from that office
what time did you actually end up
leaving the capitol
i waited until um the senate was back in
session which i believe they were
gabbled in a few minutes after um 8 p.m
and once they were back in session and
we were confident that the entire
facility was secured and cleared that
there were no individuals hiding in
closets or under desks that there were
no ieds or other suspicious devices left
behind
i left
minutes later i was probably gone by 8
30.
and mr johnny did you ever hear from
president trump that day
no
like the aeg the acting ag i spoke to
pat sapologne and
mark meadows and the vice president and
the congressional leadership but i never
spoke to the president that day
so today's hearing showcased the efforts
of the americans before us to stand up
for democracy
mr rosen mr donna you stayed steadfastly
committed to the oath they take as
officials in the department of justice
on january 6 itself they assisted during
the attack while our commander-in-chief
stayed silent
their bravery is a high moment in the
sordid story of what led to january 6.
my colleagues and i up here also take an
oath
some of them
failed to uphold theirs
and instead chose to spread the big lie
days after the tragic events of january
6
some of these same republican members
requested pardons in the waning days of
the trump administration
five days after the attack on the
capitol representative mo brooks sent
the email on the screen now
as you see he emailed the white house
quote pursuant to a request from matt
gates requesting a pardon for
representative gates himself
and unnamed others
witnesses told the select committee that
the president considered offering
pardons to a wide range of individuals
connected to the president
let's listen to some of that testimony
and
was representative gates requesting a
pardon
believe so
the the
general tone was
we may get prosecuted because we were
defensive of you know the president's
positions on these things
a pardon
that he was discussing requesting was
as broad as you could describe from
beginning a memories from the beginning
of time up until today
for eddie and all things
you mentioned nixon and i said nixon's
pardon was never nearly that broad
and
are you aware of any members of congress
i guess mr gates
and mr brooks i know
both advocated for
there'd be a blanket pardon four members
involved in that meeting and a handful
of other members that weren't at the
december 21st meeting
um
as the
part is
uh mr gates was personally pushing for a
pardon
and he was doing so since early december
i'm not sure why um she has reached out
to me
to ask if he could have a meeting with
mr meadows about receiving a
presidential party they all contacted
you
not all of them but several of them did
so you mentioned mr gates
mr fix did
mr jordan talked about congressional
pardons that he never asked me for one
there's more for an update on whether
the white house is going to pardon
members of congress
mr gomer asked for one as well
and he gives him harry asked for a card
too i'm sorry
did he talk to you directly yes he did
did uh
contact you
no she didn't contact me about it i
heard that she asked white house
counselors for a pardon
from
mr philbin
but
i didn't frequently
can you get this green are you aware of
any
conversations or communications
regarding the possibility of giving
congressman matt gates a pardon
um i know he had asked for it but i
don't know if he ever received one or
what happened with it
how do you know that congressman gates
asked for a pardon he told me
uh tell us about that
he told me it asked meadows for a pardon
were you involved in or did you witness
any conversations about the possibility
of a
blanket pardon for everyone involved in
january 6th
uh i had heard that mentioned
yeah
do you know whether the president had
any conversations about potentially
pardoning any uh
family members
um
i know he had hinted at a blanket pardon
for the january 6th thing for anybody
but i think he had for all the staff and
everyone involved not with january 6 but
just before he left office i know he had
talked about that
the only reason i know to ask for a
pardon
is because you think you've committed
a crime
thank you mr chairman i yield back
i want to thank our witnesses for
joining us today
the members of the select committee may
have additional questions for today's
witnesses
and we ask that you respond
expeditiously in writing to these
questions
without objection members will be
permitted 10 business days to submit
statements for the record
including opening remarks and additional
questions for the witnesses
without objection the chair recognizes
the gentleman from illinois for a
closing statement
thank you mr chairman the justice
department lawyers are not the
president's personal lawyers
we count on them to be on the side of
the law and to defend the best interests
of the united states
not the best interest of any political
campaign that's how it's been since the
department was founded soon after the
civil war
justice department lawyers are supposed
to play it 100 percent straight
president trump tried to erase his loss
at the ballot box by parachuting an
unqualified man into the top job at
justice it was a power play to win at
all costs with no regard for the will of
the american people
it was about ignoring millions of votes
ignore them throw them out label them
fraudulent corrupt illegal whatever
facts were clearly just an inconvenience
from the oval office president trump
urged others to bring his big lie to
life
he begged just say the election was
corrupt and leave the rest to me and the
republican congressman
he didn't care what the department's
investigations proved
what good were facts when they would
only confirm his
loss and it's no surprise that all the
far out fully fabricated whack job
conspiracy theories collapsed under even
the slightest scrutiny
that insanity went from the internet to
the highest levels of government in no
time the bottom line
the most senior leadership of the
justice department from attorney general
bill barr
to jeff rosen his successor and his
deputy rich donahue everyone except jeff
clark
was telling president trump the very
same thing the conspiracy theories were
false
the allegation of a stolen election was
a lie
the data left no room for doubt nothing
to question
and the constitution left no room for
president trump to change the outcome of
the election
but we're here today because the facts
were irrelevant to president trump
it was about protecting his very real
power and very fragile ego even if it
required recklessly undermining our in
our entire electoral system
by wildly casting baseless doubt upon it
in short he was willing to sacrifice our
republic to prolong his presidency
i can imagine no more dishonorable act
by a president
we owe a great debt of gratitude to
these men you've heard from here today
real leaders who stood for justice when
it was in grave peril
who put their country first
when the leader of the free world
demanded otherwise
they threatened to resign rather than
corrupt our democracy
and thanks largely to each of them
president trump's coup failed
contrast that to jeff clark who would do
exactly what the president wanted say
there was massive fraud
forget the facts and leave the rest of
president trump's congressional friends
mr clark refused to cooperate with this
committee he bled the fifth over 125
times why risk self in criminal
incrimination and president trump's
congressional friends
some of them are angling for pardons
they knew that every bit of what they
did was a lie and it was wrong
that's all the more reason to respect
those who came here to testify today
we thank them for their unflinching
service in the face of incredible
pressure
as it said the only thing necessary for
evil to succeed is good men to do
nothing
thankfully there were good people in the
department of justice
you heard from other good people too on
tuesday
they too defended us
but i'm still worried that not enough
has changed to prevent this from
happening again
the oath that we take has to mean
something
it has to cut to the core
of who we are
and be the driving force of our service
to this nation
we on this committee we may be able to
shine light on the darkness but that is
not enough
it's now up to every american
now and in the future
to stand for truth
to reject the lies
wherever we confront them in our towns
and our capitals and our friendships and
our families
and at the ballot box
and within our own minds and hearts
thank you mr chairman
i yield back
without objection the chair recognizes
the gentlewoman from wyoming miss cheney
for closing statement thank you very
much mr chairman and i again want to
thank the witnesses for being here today
after today i suspect that there will be
some who label you agents of the deep
state
or something else conspiratorial or
nonsensical
meant to justify ignoring what you've
said today
ignoring the facts that may be the
short-term cost of acting honorably and
telling the truth
but your actions should have an
important long-term impact
it will help keep us on the course set
by the framers of our constitution
let me paraphrase the words of john
adams and others
whether ours shall continue to be a
government of laws and not of men is
ultimately for the american people to
decide
let me also today make a broader
statement to millions of americans who
put their trust in donald trump
and these hearings so far you've heard
from more than a dozen republicans
who've told you
what actually happened in the weeks
before january 6th
you will hear from more in the hearings
to come
several of them served donald trump and
his administration
others in his campaign
others have been conservative
republicans for their entire careers
it can be difficult to accept that
president trump abused your trust
that he deceived you
many will invent excuses to ignore that
fact but that is a fact
i wish it weren't true
but it is
thank you mr chairman i yield back
again i thank our witnesses and thank my
colleagues for this hearing
as we conclude our fifth hearing in this
series
i want to remind the american people of
a few things the committee has shown
donald trump lost the 2020 election top
republican officials who supported trump
knew that he lost
and told him he lost
trump knew he lost
those who say the election was affected
by
widespread voter fraud are lying
they were lying in 2020 they were lying
in 2021
and indeed they are lying today
donald trump went to court
that's the right any candidate seeking
to challenge the outcome of an election
must do
donald trump lost in court
dozens and dozens of times
he lost in part because there was no
evidence
that voter fraud had any impact on the
results of the election
to borrow a phrase from our witness
earlier this week
mr bowers
all he had was theories
and no evidence
as i've said if you're running for
office in the united states
that's the end of the line
you accept the court's judgment you
concede the race you respect the rule of
law
and the will of the voters
but for donald trump
that wasn't the end of the land
not even close
the voters refused to keep him in office
the courts refused to keep him in office
but he continued to lie
and he went in search of anyone who
would go along
with his scheme
and we've shown today
he pressured the justice department to
act
as an arm of his reelection campaign
he hoped law enforcement officials would
give the appearance of legitimacy to his
lies
so he and his allies had some veneer of
credibility when they told the country
that the election was stolen
earlier this week
we showed how donald trump brought the
weight of the presidency
down on local and state officials
who are trying to do their jobs and
ultimately did
they investigated his claims and found
them to be false
and then they endured trump's pressure
campaign at great risk to themselves
and their loved ones
and of course
that was a scheme to get the former vice
president mike pence to violate the law
and the constitution
by rejecting the electoral college votes
on january 6
and blocking the peaceful transfer of
power
i mentioned the former vice president
last because as we showed
when he refused to bow to the pressure
in those critical moments on january 6th
that was a back-up plan
for stopping the transfer of power
the mob
and their vile threats
up to this point
we've shown the inner workings of what
was essentially a political coup
an attempt to use the powers of the
government from the local level all the
way up to overturn the results of the
election
finding the votes
send fake electors just say the election
was corrupt
along the way
we saw threats of violence we saw
what some people were willing to do
in a service of the nation
the constitution no
in service
of donald trump
when the select committee continues this
series of hearings we're going to show
how donald trump
tapped into the threat of violence how
he summoned the mob to washington and
how
after corruption and political pressure
failed to keep donald trump in office
violence
became the last option
our investigation is ongoing
those hearings have spurred an influx of
new information
that the committee and our investigators
are working to assess
we're committed to presenting the
american people with the most complete
information possible
that will be our aim when we reconvene
in the coming weeks
the chair however requests those in the
hearing room remain seated
until the capitol police have escorted
members from the room
without objection
the committee stands are joined
so
so
he's not korean